après midi à ce stade du journal
revenons maintenant sur ce geste de
zinédine zidane qui a choqué les
téléspectateurs du monde entier
un geste à la fois inexpliqués
inexplicables pardon et inexcusable pour
un champion de cette trempe
le carton rouge c'est sûr été mérité
mais on s'interroge surtout sur les
propos l'italien materazzi qui ont pu
provoquer une telle colère ce que l'on a
appris ce matin c'est que zidane était
effondrée en pleurs dans les vestiaires
après son expulsion romain messi
que s'est il passé pour que zinédine
zidane en arrive là
sur les images diffusées quelques
minutes après ce coup de tête aux voix
zidane et le défenseur materazzi
discuter après un simple accrochage de
maillot
la discussion se poursuit zidane souris
puis fait volte face après des propos
tenus par l'italien encore inconnue
zidane commet alors l'irréparable
l'arbite l'at-il vue ou l'at-il expulsé
sur la seule foi des images vidéo
rappel des faits à la 110e minute
l'arbitré interrompt le jeu car à
l'autre bout du terrain materazzi est à
terre à cet instant personne pas même
les journalistes ne semble avoir vu la
faute de zidane
que s'est il passé entre autres hervé
gaymard attribué ce prix fut rien passé
larbitre argentin monsieur lisandro n'a
pas vu l'altercation
car il suivait l'action de jeu à l'écart
dit l'un espère encore échapper à la
sanction
monsieur ly son neveu se dirige alors
vers son arbitre de touche pour le
consulter selon le vent français celui
ci aurait été avertie par le quatrième
arbitre
ici à l'image le deuxième en partant de
la gauche que zidane est bien le
responsable postés sur le bord du
terrain
il vient de voir les images sur un écran
vidéo sur la foi de ce témoignage
monsieur li 100 dos prend donc la
décision qui s'impose et sort le carton
rouge pour zidane
le geste est inexcusable et mérite
l'expulsion mais dément domenech est en
colère et dénoncent l'instauration
non-officiel de l'arbitrage vidéo
pourtant refusé par la fifa france corée
du sud au premier tour situation
comparable
autre décision patrick vieira marque un
but de la tête
injustement refusé par l'arbitré le
ballon a pourtant bien franchi la ligne
mais le corps arbitral ne l'a pas vu
l'arbitré central aurait peut-être pu
demander au quatrième arbitre de
vérifier sur la vidéo il ne l'a pas prêt
conformément aux règles en vigueur
deux poids deux mesures et des
conséquences dramatiques pour les bleus
mais qui ne remettent pas en cause le
jette malheureusement injustifiable de
zidane